all right
maddie betty welcome back
how are things been since we spoke about
a month or so ago
crazy what's what's going on uh
it's just everything's changing
we were just talking a little bit about
the drugs that are on the street seems
like that's
changed in the last week well it's
actually okay
to be completely honest it's been like
four months around that time
it was changed and prices have gone up
because
a cert like i think one of the more so
like
main people kind of
move to a new city so it's like
with that being said instead of getting
an
out a whole ounce which is like 14 grand
which is nowhere seven is a half so yeah
14 grams is like 230 dollars
instead of what we used to get at like
120
so people are getting being able to do
the jobs
and then on top of that they're mixing
fentanyl
um they're not putting in the right
chemicals they're cooking it right
which is causing people to go crazy and
then people who are
doing drugs such as germ crack crystal
weed all in one
they're really starting to go crazy
because they're mixing the drugs and not
taking care of themselves and then
listening to people who have spiritual
opinions
it's hard things for you personally
personally
i kind of moved downtown actually
instead of the back streets
i lost a few people who i thought i
trusted because of
not liking certain things that they
would do
and sticking up for myself
i had to go through some more abuse
with some friends who
who i really looked up to but i know
they're going through something
and i'm not mad at them
but to a certain point i had to
just walk away from that situation
without getting myself killed or
anything
and there's been just a lot of drama
because
people are getting competitive and
just people are getting wet competitive
competitive
they're just like if they don't like an
answer then they get super mad
or like it let's say if it's over a guy
then the girls get super
like they'll gang up on a
person and then with the
whole thing that happened with the black
guy
who died from the police it's kind of
made it harder on white people out here
i've had a couple fights because um i am
right
and i didn't even know the people but
yeah
do you long for a life
outside of this skid row situation
you do because last time we spoke you
were kind of you're talking about how
you're getting comfortable with it you
kind of like it
in some ways um i am comfortable with it
but at the same time
it's always pushing me to like want to
do better
because after being out here you're kind
of like oh this is a [ __ ]
no rules no anything and that's a total
[ __ ] lie
it's harder on a lot of people and then
you watch people
die you hear about stuff you watch
guys beat up the girls or bossing around
[Applause]
girls out here are well everybody out
here just
manipulative nobody really tells the
truth unless it's for
actually no nobody tells the truth they
just all lie
and then when somebody does tell the
truth i kind of get
blamed for like i've noticed a lot
everybody blames me i'm the first to get
blamed
and that's because i'm the youngest or
i'm the white girl or is
this the first thing they point at
because it's the easiest
and i've seen that a lot which
maybe it's the crowd of people i hang
out with and i haven't really been
hanging out with that many people
but it's hard because i don't lie i
don't steal
and it's been proven over and over and
over again
to them but it doesn't matter because
it's all about the drugs out here really
to them
the drugs and the sex
they don't think about like what it
could
what could become out of it or whose
feelings are hurting or anything
but i think a lot of my viewers
including myself watch your story listen
to your story and
think a 16 year old like yourself does
not
you know you shouldn't be on skid row
homeless doing crystal meth
and what are you doing for money now um
i'm still recycling
um i trade stuff so when i get shoes or
something
i sell them or when the looting was
going on
there's a lot of um which i didn't knock
a looting but yeah there's a lot of
merchandise that you made money off of
i'm sure it all came down to escape room
so
what would what do you see what would
help
matty um what's out of your reach right
now that actually could maybe
school school back into school and
sports
you would do what finish high school
i'd be studying 10th grade cause i
finished ninth grade but
never made it to ten so like
some kind of housing maybe away from
skid row
i'm okay i'll just get an sro and a job
because an sro even though they're
disgusting they're the way to go
actually
think about it 45 a month and it covers
water and electricity no but but but
staying on a skid row i i see that as
problematic no
not if you're inside like if you're in
an apartment people can't mess with you
no i'm not worried about the danger i
mean it helps with danger it helps with
comfort but it it's the drugs that are
still a problem
no not really i've been leaning more so
off the drugs
because they have been actually really
changing so regardless of where but but
some kind of housing provides stability
for you
um i really just think like
in school i just really want to get back
in school
and then i'm gonna start doing some
classes at the trade college tech thing
latc lattc yeah
and um right now
even though i kind of moved to a new
place and everything
i am living with um my uncle
and the girl that i call my mom even
though she's not my mom and they've been
giving me
more structure oh so you've been staying
with your uncle um he's not really my
uncle but
i call him my uncle always
and who are they they're an older couple
yeah and they're looking out for you or
oh yes they're like i have like rules to
stay there like i have to clean
to being at a certain time i have to
call them every 30 minutes when i'm gone
so they know i'm okay this is this is
what this is their apartment
um no it's still a tent but better than
nothing
so you're still in a tent on the street
but i have been like
learning a lot more and it's been more
like so family
like but not too overwhelming
and they're not trying to control me
because when you try to control a team
they're gonna run or you're gonna push
them away being overbearing
and being out here you know
i've gotten all my partying out of me
and
partying sucks it doesn't seem fun doing
drugs
is not as fun as it thinks because all
you do out here is just party
drink smoke and
it's nothing it's not life and
most people get carried away when
they're in college or
drop out of college or when they're
young adults
kind of get stuck in that because they
haven't
done it at a young age but you see
plenty of people here that are double
triple
four times your age and they're um where
are they where do they
a lot of people who are older than me i
would say i'm
a lot more mature than most people
and then when it comes to like rule
following no but my point is they're
still living on the street in tents
um yeah they don't really care they
don't see themselves going anywhere
but i don't blame them because
a lot of them have been in jail or
prison and i mean since they're kids
like
younger than what i am right now and it
kind of [ __ ] them up like they've had
that structure all that time
but they're not able the government
doesn't see them as equal
and i feel like let's say a person get
hurt by somebody
and do something to that person at like
the age of 10
and then be in jail until the 21
um it's really not fair for them
mentally because
they're missing so many things and then
they don't have an equal opportunity so
they just might as well stay where they
are
it's like people who have
histories shouldn't really be
held accountable to it for the most part
i think they should get an
equal opportunity when they're out here
or just out here in the world after they
served their time because
they already served their time they're
already punished for something that
they've done
right so why punish them more that's why
they're out here most people
out here hate it most people out here
know that there is nothing better for
them because
they can't get a job like a normal
person
they've lost so many times people judge
them because the tattoos that they had
were
or things that are on their records and
it's not fair it's just whatever
like how recently there was a cop in
lapd
who got taken off the um force because
some girl said
he raped her so many years ago but they
had no evidence but they didn't question
her
why would she just come so many years
later when she could have done it
right then and there because they're not
far in age
so with that being said just
from that story it's like
did he even rape her or did she get mad
at him
and just say that so many years later
and just
just to ruin his life
because a lot of people just want to
ruin people
just to cover up somebody else or save
themselves
but what i see in regards to you is
if you spend enough time down here on
skid row you'll eventually
probably get a similar arrest record
and you'll start doing more extreme
things to make
ends meet or to get your drug or do
whatever
and that's what i think you know at your
young age
i think myself and a lot of viewers see
an opportunity to change your direction
i wouldn't like it does kind of seem
like that but
for me it's been
i thought that i would be more like
following people
and i'm actually starting to more so
very towards my own lane
that's great even though it's harder
because there's a lot of hate out here
i just it scares me it scares me seeing
everybody else
well there's a much better life outside
of skid row in case you're not aware
yeah i know that i know that's for sure
and it's like following rules
okay i used to like being a rule breaker
but oh
i don't even like jaywalking now
it's like or like if the police come
just shut the [ __ ] up and let them do
their talking
because i really i don't know i just
i want to become a nurse and a lot of
people have been saying
oh why are you going to nursing why do
you go to the trade college because
you like to take care of people and like
but it's whatever i'm kind of stuck in a
spot right now
all right maddie well thank you for
coming back and filling us in on what's
going on with you
and let's see if we can kind of maybe do
something to help you out
guys should have like a i don't know
like
almost like a camp for people to come
out here
and like spend a week or two and see
what
like have a different viewpoint of
what it's like on the streets and what
it could be like for people
but also how people are out here because
even though they seem like they're crazy
a lot of them have stories
and are just mentally ill or just
act like it because
after a while people like to tear you
down out here and
really don't like anybody being happy
because
they're not happy and
or people can't stick up for the wrong
doing
because that person has a name
or a reputation and we can't change
that because people are scared because
it is true people do get killed out here
or found behind dumpsters
and it's no joke and a lot of people get
away with it
do you have any dreams of what you'd
like to see happen in your life is
nursing
something you're thinking about nursing
um i like to travel
yeah um
i've been completely honest what is the
biggest mount it's not mount everest
isn't mount everest
mount everest is pretty big the biggest
mountain in the world
in the world might be kilimanjaro i'm
not sure mm-hmm
kilimanjaro might be well whatever the
biggest one is i think mount everest is
probably big
yeah pretty sure it's my neighbors but i
want to hike that
and even though that sounds stupid and
crazy
i remember watching a video and it is
kind of dangerous but that's like my
old grandma kind of to-do list bucket
list
it's good to have dreams and get a car
one day
oh and maybe play for the wnba
because i've been practicing basketball
a lot and i've been pretty good actually
even though i still got a lot of
learning to do but
awesome all right maddie let's stay in
touch and we'll see where
welcome see what we can do thanks
you